هذا ما قاله وزير الدفاع سابقا ان ان
اغلاق رد هيل هي الامر الصائب بالنسبه لي
قواتنا وعائلاتهم وكذلك
لامننا القومي
وزير الدفاع ايضا ورئيسه الاركان المشتركه
سيعقداني
اجتماع السابع لمجموعه الاتصال الخاصه
باوكرانيا
لمناقشه الجهود المستمر لتزويد اوكراني
تحتاج اليه
لصديق العدوان الروسي على الاراضيها وشكرا
لكم المزيد من التفاصيل ايضا وزير الدفاع
سيسافر يوم الجمعه في رحله الى كندا
واندلسيه وكامبو
المنتدى منتدى الدفاع ويركز فيها على
الهيكل الدفاعيه قمه
وزير الدفاع الوطني
في الوقت الذي تعمل فيه الولايات المتحده
ويندوز على
خطي طريق جديد وفي كامبودي هسه يشارك وزير
الدفاع في اجتماع 8 لوزاره الدفاع رابطه
جنوب جنوب شرق اسيا اذن هذه ستكون اول
المشاركه
للوزير في المنتدى والتي شارك فيها
افتراضيه
استمرار لتقليد طويل المدى اللي مشاركه
الولايات المتحده في اجتماعات ذلك المنتدى